[Musique]
le nombre de vaccins qu'astrazeneca
envisage de livrer à la france
fond comme neige au soleil le contrat
initial signé à l'automne prévoyait 17
millions et demi de doses pour le
premier trimestre de cette année contre
a réduit de moitié en décembre puis à
nouveau divisé par deux passant ainsi à
4 millions 600 mille doses d'ici au mois
de mars
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu ne peux pas rentrer dans mon bureau
ce n'est pas une blague
l'activité commence à tomber et c'est le
cas du tout est tombé à écouter à vous
merci claude moi j'aime vraiment bien
discuter avec vous hier le figaro
révélait que le président hésite entre
trois nuances de re confine on parle le
même depuis cet après-midi de
confinement très serré où on dirait un
film sulfureux à regarder on est
aujourd'hui à 50 2 % 1 de français qui
sont favorables à ce confinement mais
attention un confinement qui serait
similaire à celui de la période de
novembre à mi décembre le deuxième
confinement quand on compare à celui de
mars
ils ne sont que 48 % des français à y
être favorables en tout cas c'est une
période de crise qui est difficilement
vécue par les français qui sont
interrogés des mesures strictes
voilà donc l'entreprise est maintenu
dans les semaines qui viennent
tout à fait et il faut qu'on vive avec
cette idée que ça ça va survenir demain
ça va survenir après demain on va vivre
très longtemps avec 7 avec cette maladie
qui ramenait du taboulé pour la fête des
points
êtes fatigué
on n'est pas fatigués qui ça qui ça
les démons minuit
adieu petit monde d'avant parti beaucoup
trop tôt pouvoir monter sur scène coûte
que coûte pour maintenir l'expérience du
concert quitte à en fermer son public
dans des petites bulles c'est l'idée à
la fois géniale et perturbante 1 de ce
groupe de rock alternatif de flamming
lips qui a tenté cette expérience ce
week-end à oklahoma city
alors vous le voyez sur ces images assez
impressionnante le public est donc dans
cette huile collègues jusqu'à 3 s'ils
sont bien sûr confinés ensemble cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sait plus trop quoi
il semblerait malheureusement si la
crise sanitaire ne s'arrange pas et bien
que ça devienne la norme ce genre de
concert et quand on regarde en fait ces
images prouvent qu'elles sont assez
symbolique de notre époque c'est à dire
celle des réseaux sociaux de
l'individualisme grandissant où chacun
vit comme ça et voit le monde dans sa
petite bulle les ventana de retour le
lâcher l'ouverture du poulet
et ça glousse le mandat de donald trump
représente sans conteste un tournant
dans l'histoire du fact checking et les
journalistes qui ont dû vérifier les
déclarations du président américain
n'ont pas beaucoup dormi pendant 4 ans
au total il aura prononcé 30 1573
mensonge selon le washington post
soit en moyenne plus de 20 par jour j'ai
trouvé déjà une électrice pour nadine
morano jouir
je vous jure que c'est vrai ce que je
vais vous le dire ma fille était venue
m'aider
ces temps où j'étais un peu malade et
elle vit aux états unis à lui à new york
elle a voté pour trump elle était un peu
mari mais elle m'a dit si j'étais en
france je veux trait à la présidentielle
pour nadine morano dans l'ensemble trump
a davantage menti sur l'économie la
fiscalité le commerce extérieur et
l'emploi au total sur toutes ces
questions il a prononcé 7568 mensonge
par ailleurs les deux thèmes principaux
de sa fin de mandat le coronavirus et
l'élection présidentielle lui ont donné
du grain à moudre il a prononcées
respectivement sur chacun de ces sujets
2519 et 3035 intox les deux bergers
allemands de joe biden et ils ont pris
leurs quartiers à la maison blanche
quelques jours après leur maître ils ont
annoncé eux mêmes via leurs comptes
twitter oui parce qu'ils ont un compte
twitter
soixante seize mille abonnés c'est plus
que nous trois réunis ont quand même
cente médor ont même eu droit à une
inauguration une cérémonie d'investiture
le dos au mur et vous pour chiens avec
un concert devant d'anvers
sans raison il s'agit de vivre sinon je
vais lui laisser un message
bonjour je suis la seule qui si tous les
techniciens qui sont inscrits ou sur rtl
sont très mal à l'aise
après il ya de la gêne il faut le dire
et tout le monde se demande si vous
n'êtes pas un peu aviné mais bon tu as
tenté de s'enfuir avec la bouteille de
whisky ou es ce que vous avez vu une
bouteille de whisky
j'en ai vu une là bas sur le comptoir
quand qu'est ce qu'on fait à dix mois
vous pouvez me faire un câlin
[Musique]
observatoire qui tourne pour moi
incontrôlable l'homme se débat
violemment rata je veux plus vous allez
fort c'est plus ça va faire mal
berlin voit là soit tu mon arrêt sur ed
mais c'est pas si attention le port le
sens du jour
comment ne pas être délogés par la
police il appelle les gaz et du sein il
est complètement fou complètement
flasque complètement liquide même et là
on peut plus le regard il est trop
grande je suis 90 kg le traditionnel
message de bienvenue à bord des trains
parodier savoir histoire
je la connais pas
un voyageur a enregistré l'annoncent peu
banal entendu lors de son trajet
guingamp paris réseau social je vous
invite à engager la conversation avec
votre voisin si votre voisine vous le
savez déjà pas de restauration et ce
jusqu'à notre arrivée en gare terminus
en effectuant ce test afin d'évaluer
l'endurance de nos voyageurs désigne
parvenait à tenir jusqu'au bout
eh bien vous pourrez vous inscrire à
l'émission koh lanta dans quelques
années ne passeront parmi vous n'hésitez
pas sollicité lors de notre passage dans
votre voiture
de quoi vous avez besoin on vous
expliquera comment faisant passer pour l
esi régis je vais le dire coût du non
regarde le sondage
oui à 75% et donc à prévoir ça c'est
juste un complot remo savoie la gym que
des jeunes dans les enfants aujourd'hui
pense que maintenant on peut tous se
battait pour y croire